okay thanks uh I mean to the organizers
for this super nice workshop and also
for inviting me to to give this this
talk I must say that the talk is a bit
of a challenge because uh there are many
people in the audience who knows a lot
about topological order or topological
error correcting codes or maybe there
are others who never ever in their lives
heard about the toric code or things
like that so then I decided to to
introduce topological order in a kind of
not very standard way for Quant
information
and I would try to give more a flavor of
the condensed matter kind of background
of the political order that by the way
it was the origin of the political order
I mean the the very definition of the
political order by by when appear in the
understanding of of condensed matter
systems uh okay
so let me just I mean put the setup I
mean we we will be I mean considering
regular latices that say for Simplicity
the square Lattis and then in each kind
of point of the Lattis we will have a
particle will be a spin s particle and
this essentially means that the local
dimension of the hbert spaces in each of
the sites is okay 2 s plus one most of
the cases we can think of having I mean
spin one half particles and this mean
that the local Dimension is two so we
have cubits
okay okay they in nature I mean
particles do not interact all with all
or at least is not the usual thing
because of course the ation strength
Decay with distance and usually Decay
very fast so in most cases they I mean
one particle interact only with those
which are close
by uh and then okay the interaction is
is nothing but of course a heran matrix
that if for instance one particle
interact with another I mean there are
four particles interacting then R is
equal to four and then the interaction
is simply AR mat of size D 4 * D
4 uh we will always assume also that the
interaction are uniform so that kind of
particles interact the same way with the
close by particles no matter in which
position they are in the
latice and then if if I consider one
interaction H and I put it in in in the
latis position
I then I have h i and the hon is nothing
by the sum of all these interactions
okay the hamiltonian is is just the
energy observable and it's the one that
kind of governs the evolution of the
system as you probably know okay there
is one object important in this context
which is the ground State the ground
state is nothing but the normalized igen
vector of minimal igen value of the
hamiltonian and it's kind of the stable
state so the state that you get if you
cool the system down to temperature
equal to
zero okay even the the the aim of the
talk is that even if the particles
interact only with those which are close
by the entanglement in the ground state
can have a very Global nature and this
kind of global entanglement which is
called topological entang entanglement
or topological order and the talk is
exactly about this how can it be that if
even if the particles only talk with
those that are close by if you cool the
system then what you get is a
entanglement it's pretty weird
entanglement it's a very very Global
entanglement uh and the nice thing is
that this is not just a mathematical
statement I mean that you have to cook
up a super strange hamiltonian in such a
way that the ground state no I mean
there are very natural hamiltonians in
nature for which the ground state is
topologically over so these things these
topologically ordered systems are out
there okay and there are example that
the fractional Quantum hle effect St
High TC superc conductors some spin
liquids like that
okay good okay so which is the aim of
The Talk The a of the talk is to okay at
least partially try to to attack three
questions one is is more historical
probably so where does topological order
come
from the second is a bit more
mathematical is how can one Define it
formally so sense that one has really a
definition of what topological order is
uh the third of course is then no now we
know what topological order is how can
we constr examples of systems with
topological order and then of course
open problems that may I mean you may be
interested in thinking or knowing that
are important or some people working on
them or
whatever
okay so before starting even to talk
about topological order it would be nice
to talk about order because I mean what
what does order mean in this
context and then okay so I mean the
concept of order comes Associated to the
con concept of pH and is a face okay so
if you think of a face of nature then
you think of ice liquid solid I mean I
mean you have water and you increase the
temperature you decrease the temperature
and you know that there are different
faces there no okay this is the picture
now how can we go a bit more in DET and
understand which is the difference for
instance between ice and liquid now if
we look at the particles in a liquid or
in a gas phase they move freely I mean
they're completely
disordered but if we go to the to the to
the to the ice to the solid they I mean
are arranged in a crystal so in a latis
and then just looking at this you one SE
or one Med see that these things are
order so there are some order here in
the particles where if you have all of
them kind of moving around there is no
order there so this is kind of the
picture one has so here particles are
order and here they are disorder how can
one formalize the fact that one in one
case particles are order and the other
are disorder and the nice thing is that
one can do this based on symmetries so
you take water or gas and then you you
take a piece of it and you move it I
mean a real in a I mean no matter in
which direction no matter how how much
you find exactly the same
thing however in the ltis you can I mean
to to recover exactly the same structure
you can only move particles that I mean
something which is proportional to the
ltis distance because otherwise you get
something different so in a sense this
system has less symmetry than this in
this you can move you can translate the
system I mean arbitrary real uh
distances and here you have kind of this
latis distance so you have less Symmetry
and then essentially this is kind of the
the the the the main thing that you can
understand that you are ordering more of
the particles if you are breaking some
of the symmetries of the system yes but
um in the gas it's kind of like a random
assignment of locations right and then I
would assume that there's no way how you
can translate it so that you get the
same again so in what sense is it the
same because I mean if you look at the
system here and you look at the system
here you see the difference you you
cannot see in which position you are by
moving the well there might be some I
don't know a random cluster here and if
I move no but the gas are particles are
freely moving there's no no
no so how this question makes sense
because so when you are saying that
there is a translational symmetry for
the crystal mhm right so that assumes
that the locations form like a group and
therefore you can can talk about
translational symmetry but like in the
gas there is no topology like there is
no group a priori on the particles so
you cannot talk about like any symmetry
of the ground state with respect to
anything because there was not that
group statistical yeah we're talk about
statistical yes it's not exactly right
you can't map exactly the molecules on
the molecule but statistics but then the
the um if I'm talking about like the
possible configurations in gas so that I
move move and have another possible
configuration then this also holds for
lses because a lce that has the the
points here is as possible as a lce that
has the point slightly shifted so no no
no but the ltis positions are fixed yeah
but then you could say the gas position
also fixed no no no no in a particular
snapshot they fixed I mean never mind I
mean I don't want to get stuck in this
first slide because it has nothing to do
with the rest of the top it's just it's
just I mean the way the way to
understand which is order and which is
disorder and how one can motivate by the
fact that there is some Symmetry and
some breaking symmetry if you want let's
go to the quantum case which is the next
slide and it's even more clear because
of course this is I mean this is one
canot talk about ground state here
because there are temperature so I mean
ground state is something you need I
mean this are kind of thermal States and
things like that so so let's go to the
quantum case if you want and if you want
to keep the discussion let's the
discussion here okay so let's let's
let's talk about the quantum case now I
only trying to be intuition of why some
order is associated to some broken
symmetry I mean not trying to give now a
theorem or or anything like that so so
let's now go to the quantum case I mean
Quantum phes that occur at zero
temperature okay now of course we cannot
vary the temperature to change between
the phases because we are at zero
temperature so but we can VAR the
parameters in the hamiltonian and then
by buing the parameters in the
hamiltonian we can have a system which
is ordered like this one in which of
course it's clear that that there is
some order I mean the spins are all of
them poting in the same direction we can
have something different which is a spin
spin
liquid and a spin liquid is is a state
in which all symmetries are preserved so
it's a state in which the Symmetry I
mean you have traditional invariance
imagine that we are even in both cases
we're in a latis so in this system you
you can translate the system I mean
imagine you are in a t you can translate
the system this is invariant you also
have local rotation symmetry if you
rotate all the spins with with with the
same rotation all of them the system is
also invariant so it has all possible I
mean you can also have kind of if you
rotate the system like that it's also
invariant so you have all possible
symmetries I mean again in a latis uh
here is clear that you don't have all
symmetries because of course if in this
state you rotate rotates all spin at the
same time you get a different state okay
you rotate all of them from up to down
to get something completely
different uh it's not clear at all from
the beginning that this SP liquid EX
system exist or not but I mean they
exist okay at least in theory uh but I
mean this is why they are called spin
liquids because they are the analog of
the liquid in which you have kind of all
symmetries and this is I mean some kind
of pherom magnetic state in this case
and you have some order here so these
are this order system this are order
system and again the inition is because
okay you have some kind of I mean you
see and you see that the particles are
ordered and if you want to
mathematically formalize it the way to
see it is that these locals S2 symmetry
so the fact that by rotating all spins
in the same direction H this state is
invariant this state is no longer
invariant under that so there is a
symmetry which is this local S2 symmetry
which is
broken so again there is a connection
between phase this is one phase this are
the different phase with concept of
order so this is order this is
disordered and with a concept of a
symmetry breaking there is a symmetry
here which is broken here and there is a
third concept which is how you detect
that this symmetry is broken
and in this case it's super easy you
just take the sigma C operator okay in
in in one position forance in this
position and you take the expectation
value in this case this is one and in
this case this is
zero okay so there is a local operator
which even has a physical meaning which
is the magnetization per particle that
distinguish both faces in what in which
in the in the disorder phase because you
have the Symmetry the observable is zero
and in the order phase the observable is
not zero
so and this is called a local order
parameter's I I is simply one position
the one you prefer because the system is
traditional invariant a single position
it's a sigma C operate a sigma C in
position I so when you say
zero well this is zero I mean this is
expectation value of this observable
against this state so some of them are
pointing up no no no but this is I mean
I I cannot I I of course I I cannot I
cannot draw the system because I just
just just a pictorial it's just a
pictorial thing of of of of of something
that I cannot draw because it's it's a
Tang State I cannot draw a picture of it
okay but that means that something that
is like um kind of like an a cat state
or something where it's a superposition
between all pointing up and all pointing
down which sounds very ordered to me but
it would still have um the expectation
zero right for this observable yes okay
yes yes yes definitely but but it does
not mean that I mean you you you can
detect this phase uh the fact that you
have all up down all down differently
but but I
mean I mean this state is very
particular the one of all up plus all
down because you have this plus and
minus but let's talk to this later if
you want but let's let's again I'm
trying just simply to construct some
intuition of of of of the concept of
order and on these things it's not I
don't want to be okay so so again uh
there is a a local order parameter so
it's called order parameter because it's
a parameter we detects the order and
it's called local because it's a local
observable of the story okay and then
this is the landow approach to faces uh
is is the following so there can be
different types of order for instance
the fer of pherom magnetic order this
one antiferromagnetic order in which the
particles are line spin up down up down
up down or other orders like we will see
others in the in the in in the
presentation the next thing is that they
are characterized by a broken Symmetry
and this symmet is detected by some
order parameter which is
local and I mean this approach to faces
has been extremely successful in con
matter essentially I mean after the 0s
All Phases pH Transitions and whatever
were able to be classified and studied
with this with this approach okay yes um
so just make sure I'm understand this
correctly are you trying to say that if
you want to distinguish between ordered
and disordered system there also exists
some local observable which will give
that away basically it might not be zi
but yes yes not I mean not in a
topologically order case this is exactly
what I'm going to talk about now there
are and this is the pre topological
order approach to faces but now we will
see that there are some phes some states
for which this does not work okay this
is kind of
the there are kind of like sell the
topological when when is this all up
Plus or down that some have some of the
feature of topological order but they
don't have others we will see it if you
on later when we when we when we when we
talk about this this so you haven't
actually defined phases you're you're
giving us different ways of
distinguishing exactly I I didn't I
uh it's not defined no it can be defined
but again this definition if you want a
mathematical definition is subtle and
and if you want I will give it at the
end of the talk with ph is
essentially okay but so again I mean
this is the way that condense matter I
mean usually thing I mean they have
examples they they they give names to
the examples and they give similar names
if the example are similar and then out
of this the mathematical physicist I try
to write definitions and then have to
prove theor and whatever so I'm now in
the matter point of view of giving
examples and giving names to examples
and with this you have an idea of why of
how things are called let's say
okay and order is a property of the um
of a Quantum state or is it a property
of the uh Spa uh lowest energy space of
the
honi very good question uh no it's a
very good
question in principle in most of this I
mean essentially in cond matter you
always talk about hon and therefore for
is a property of the ground space of the
Hamilton if you want and this is exactly
why this all up Plus or down is not
topological because if you have a system
with this ground state you also have the
ground state all up and the ground state
all down and they are topologically
ordered so because so it's kind of first
you have this interaction or something
like that so this is clear not toal in
the ground space you have Pro States
okay even if you have a superposition
which can have some features of being
non locally detectable okay like this
but anyhow okay so uh let's
move to topological order so in the '
80s uh kind of there were two
two two systems one is the fractional
Quantum effect and the other is the
height super conductor that kind of in a
sense challenge this landow view of of
understanding faces uh we'll concentrate
on on on this High TC super conductors
we won't talk about how super
conductivity at all but we will talk
about the resonating balance B state
which was kind of one of the one of the
one of the state that was postulated by
Anderson to explain how this is super
conductivity and this rbb is resonating
balance one state and then uh
understanding this state is is not easy
and there are many open questions even
now I will talk about some of them later
uh but there is a even a simplification
of this which is called the quantum dier
model that was kind of goes back to Roan
and gson and then we'll talk about this
Quantum D model uh because it's the the
one of the first places in which one me
topological order
appeared so we have a a square lce and
then we have uh I mean whenever I draw
something like like this a DI like that
I'm I'm thinking in a singlet okay
singlet is okay up down minus down up or
if you want 0 one- one Z of course in
order to
specify uh I mean I need to to order I
mean to have kind of directions in the
edges in such a way that I specify the
sign of that uh but I mean I will forget
about the sub so assume that there is
a AR range order of the of the I mean
directions in the in the edges and then
for Clear which is the first particle
and which the second particle in any of
these
signs and then I call configuration to a
covering of the latis a covering means
that I put I I put this this this these
these diers in such a way that each
vertex belongs to one and only one of
them them
okay uh there are POS different possible
configurations one is this one for
instance okay one is this one okay there
are many
others the problem one of the main
problems to to to understand the the
kind of re resonating B Bon state that I
will Define in a while uh is the fact
that these configuration are not
orthogonal between
themselves uh so then with ro and said
okay let's remove this problem and we
will by definition
assume that this configurations are
orthogonal okay there is a second
problem and is the fact that in your
hbert space there are of course states
that are not
configurations and this is another
problem and they decided to also forget
about this problem by restricting the
hbert space to the space span by the
configurations and this is the Quantum
dver model the quantum D model is a
model in which I have a hbert space
which is the orthogonal span of all
possible configurations of the r
okay yes so on configuration you mean
the T or product of those exactly t or
product of things like that exactly
exactly exactly this exactly what Sor
what you call the orthogonal of things
that are notal no no because we made
them orthogonal we Define a space we now
we call this configuration an object we
for we forget for a while that these
things are singlets and we call them
kind of red uh I mean whatever I mean
diers or red diers or whatever uh I
forget where they come from
uh even if I have I have in mind where
they come from in order to give physical
interpretation to the things I get later
but I mean is to understand to to for
the mathematics I forget where they come
from okay so we can think of them as
particles that they are not exactly if
you want yes yes
but uh okay then I have a hamiltonian
which is this Quantum hamiltonian which
is this hamiltonian there it has two
parameters T is always positive and it
come with a minus sign and B can be B
can be both positive or negative so
let's see what what this hamiltonian
doeses so so this since it has a
negative sign I mean this kind of put
energy bonus if you resonate resonate
means that if you have I mean two diers
like that then you would also have them
you would like also to have them like
that okay because this this gives you
energy if you do this I mean not gives
you I mean this removes energy if you do
this in this case if V is positive you
penalize how two ders in parall one
close to the other and if it's negative
you put a bonus on
that this and this is the hamiltonian
okay so this is the resonating term and
this is the ter that penalizes or not
having diers in parall then we go to the
limits so let's take v/ T going to minus
infinity so this means that I'm taking v
h since T is positive I taking V
negative and large larger much larger
than T in Absol value and then of course
I if I have diers in parallel I mean I
have a huge energy bonus so the system
tend to put dimers in
parallel therefore in this limit the the
ground state of the system is this
column State okay there not just one
many columns so the ground state is not
unique but one of them is this column
State okay so I have a crean order
system it's a column order okay if I go
to the other limit V / T goes to ER
Infinity then V is is is now H positive
and therefore I penalize a
lot having diers in parallel so of
course I have to avoid this and I have
this stagger order in which I I I do not
have a single Diary in par to another
okay so there a different type of order
it's clear that this part that this this
is an order system at least from the
picture but this a different type of
order what happens in between and this
is interesting case so this is called
the AR I mean Ros AR some point and this
when V is equal to T and in this case
the ground state of the system is the
resonating balance Bond State the resona
balance state is the equal way
superposition of all possible
configurations and this cor resonating
balance State because we make
all I we make all di resonate in all
possible ways okay with this and this is
the the the the the point in which I
mean we have some topological order so
this is the thing we are interested in
and it's also the the state that kind of
was postulated by Anderson to explain
High TC super conductivity so the first
thing is that this RvB
yes when you say row order colum row is
just as good right yes yes of course of
course of course of sort of it's like
the icing model of picks one of them
yeah exctly so the ground state is gener
you have this you have also the
translated you have the rotated yeah of
course I just picture one of
them it it's known to be the ground
state or it's believed to be I mean it's
the usual thing I mean it seems it seems
it should be know because this have I
mean this is infinite energy compared to
this so you can assume this is this this
is no longer there and now if you have
only this term it's clear this is the
ground state but it's it's only in the
infinite limit yeah yeah you want yeah
yeah it's kind of yeah yeah there could
be made perturbations around
this island vertical and horizontal
large islands that's almost that's
also yes yes yes
yes no this this is I think rated have
that to yeah this is of course yeah of
course of course I mean I agree I agree
I mean if you to the infinite limitting
which you remove
this I mean it's clear that this is this
has the minimal possible energy of
course it's not the unique one so there
could be many others like rows or and
there could be more complicated ones
also I'm not claiming they are not over
I may ask at this arcade point when it's
this at this point the you know the RvB
state is the ground state is this is
this is no this this is no okay I see
sorry this put a bonus I mean you have
something like that then you should also
have something like
that because this give you an energy
bonus if you do
this so we are concentrating in this in
this point and this is this is kind of
the original work of of R an they show
that this is really the ground state of
at this point
okay so okay so this state does not
break any symmetry now we are back to
the fact that in which we assume that
this these These diers are made out of
singlets since they are sing they have
su2 invariance so this we have for free
and in in I mean this this system does
have also that do have traditional
invariance are yes St is just the equal
way superposition of all possible
configurations so these are just tens
prods each one of these configuration is
a tensor prod of these things and this
is the equal way superposition of all
possible ways of putting the diers in
the in the
lce uh okay it was postulated by
Anderson to explain how this super
conductivity and maybe I can even say a
couple of words of why this has anything
to do with super conductivity and the
nice thing is that this a candidate for
a new unobserved up to now but there are
many candidates for that pH in nature
which is a topological spin liquids that
this the spin liquid is clear the F that
is topological is what I'm going to talk
about now okay so it has all the
features of theological
model for that indeed one needs a
frustrated latice so a square ltis is
not good for that so we need a
triangular or a c latis but this not a
problem because indeed there are real
materials for which the natural latis is
a c latis this is a experimental paper
indeed in which they show this and the
nice thing of the ca is that it seem
that the simplest interactions the
antiferromagnetic interaction of I mean
High interaction gives the RvB as a
ground state so really there are very
natural interactions the most natural
one indeed that gives this RvB seems to
be give this RvB as a ground state and
there is kind of a numerical paper of
white and from his group in science
showing this what's a frustrated lce
good question a frustrated ltis is in
most in most of these situations our our
hon has some antiferromagnetic
interaction antiferromagnetic means that
if one spin is up the other should be
down the closest one so you have in your
in your in your in your a triangle this
is impossible to satisfy at the same in
all in all Bs you have a you have a
square it's clear that they can put this
up down down up and everyone is happy
but if I have a triangle if I put here
up and I put here down I cannot make
this this this this note happy because
if I put down this is bad for that if I
put up this is bad for that so this is
why if you have triangles your R is
called frustrated because you cannot
simultaneously in this antiferromagnetic
interactions make everyone happy so it's
something like not to
col yes exactly you want yes exact
exactly this exactly you want exactly
this um
good okay so then let's let's try to see
because we I didn't find yet topological
order is which are the special
properties of this rbb that allow people
to call it topological order why do you
I no this this will come this this will
come later I mean
try to give an idea of why but
uh okay so
uh okay Direction okay this so which is
the topological content of the of this
Quantum D model so let's let's do a
couple of very trival things so one is
I'm going to draw two lines one like
that and one like that and then I
realize immediately that if I count the
number of diers that cut this line in
this case is even in both cases two two
if I take a different configuration it's
also even and if I take any other
configuration it's also even so this is
always like
that moreover I can go from any
configuration to any other configuration
just by resonating moves a resonating
move is whenever they have two things in
parallel I put them in paral like that
okay so for instance if I start in the
column State and I want to arrive to
this one then it's CC first of all I
resonate these two to get these two I
resonate this other two to get this
other two and then I
resonate uh what the middle one to get
this one and I'm in this state okay and
I can do it from I mean to go from the
column state to any other
state uh okay and the nice thing is that
these two features can be changed and
they are changed if I change the
topology and this is quite topological
order there in which I put my my my
system so now I take Aus Aus mean that
now I mean I'm also allowed to connect
this particle with this particle and
then what I can do simply for instance
if I take these two diers I can move
them up just one one one side no like
this okay now I have a DI here another D
connecting the up with the down because
I have a to I can no problem and then I
I see that of course now the number of
cuts of this line is is no longer
even okay moreover this is also easy to
see if you pay a bit there is no way to
go from this state to the previous blue
one so the one in which I didn't do this
Movement by local resonating moves no
way uh and then I get sectors which I
call topological sectors that are simply
characterized by by by by I mean all
states that are connected by locally
resonating move so within each sector
like I connect any P by local resonating
moves and from one sector to another
sector I cannot connect by locally
resonating moves can you Lo is simply I
have two things like that I put them
like that and vice versa that's
it uh okay and then one one can see how
these seor sectors are are labeled and
here is where the frustrated L is enter
if I if I have a square lce I have a I
mean many sectors really I mean there
there is essentially uh I mean in an
infinite lce there are infinite of them
let say there's no no bound on that uh
if I have a triangular at I have only
four sectors and this is a nice thing so
and the sectors are are are a um labeled
by exactly the parity of the number of
diers that intersect these reference
lines this one and another way I I don't
understand whether you're talking about
infinite or finite L thises because
everything that relates to parities
doesn't make sense no no no I'm talking
about part I mean what I talk about
infinite If I Grow the Lattis what I
mean is that the number of sector grow
with the system size oh okay and grow
unboundedly with theist size this what
I'm talking about going to the infinite
case okay but then what I do is to I go
to a frustrated l so triangular or or C
both both are exactly the same in this
case and in this case the number of
sector is four and they are simply
labeled by the parity of the number of
of diamond that cut two reference lines
and they have the sector even even the
sector even OD the sector o even and the
sector OD OD and there are no more
sectors okay so the par is the same
however you put it yes it doesn't matter
where do I put
yes and then the nice thing because
remember that I'm interested in the ar
ar ar points where I have the resonating
balance B state if I if I have now this
this this topology of atus then I I mean
the ground states are I mean I have one
ground state per sector and the ground
state is exactly the resonating B is one
state within the sector
okay so for inance in the cas of theang
I have four sectors so I have the genery
four okay and the nice thing is that I
mean to know in which sector I am I
cannot detect it locally because I have
to count parity and to count parity you
have to really go through a whole loop
around the tus and this is not a local
thing so I canot detecting which sector
I am by something local I have to do
some nonlocal counting to to know which
sector I
am okay and this essentially gives all
the feature of the political order so
let's see
yes explain one more time yes what
happened when that allow
shft yeah exactly if if I if I'm in Aus
I'm able to connect the up the upper
particles with the down particles I see
and all the configurations have
every node is connected to something
right yes so I see so that's before I
was not able to do
this
but you would be if you would have one
more note on top and one more note on
the bottom no of course the fact that it
was even even depends also on the on the
size of the system but it simply that
that what I mean is you add just two
veres no but of course then you have to
fill the rest of the ltis also of course
so so even in an infinite lce when you
build your your limits you always
consider Square cuts of the yes yes yes
yes I'm
Yes again this is just a motivation to
understand the difference between
putting a to or not putting a to of
course you can play with with a strange
shapes and the properties will change
but yes sectors are just connected
components in the configuration exact
exactly that thetically exactly that and
you might ask where not only like the
connected components but also if there
is like a small cut that could be
equally devastating or not devastating
whatever as a complete cut right so so
with each sector could be like a
bottleneck which I mean you still can go
through but be very little so you are
not concerned with this kind of say or I
so I think I didn't understand the
question so so so you consider the the
connected components of the
configuration I so each connected
component is a se but now you might be
concerned like how connected really is a
connected component connected component
can have Val it's either like an
expounder graph or it can have of course
a very small cut which could be which
would be almost like yes inde apart inde
in the Square lce there are components
in sectors with a single Vector for this
stack stacker faces they are the only I
mean in the in the in the collective
components they are the only it's just
one point so of course the the collected
components in the Square ratic can be
very strange there could be ones with
many many many
ER States and ways of moving and there
could be ones with a single state so
this is why the square lce is not
probably the right the right place to to
do this and these frustated lates are
much better because in this frustated
ltis I mean things are much more robust
that there many ways to go from one to
from one configuration to another but
but of course I'm not considering how
fast can I which as the number of moves
I have no no I mean simply if you can or
if you you cannot just
yes not at all uh what are
the you tell me did you say with
the yeah sorry yes is this this and this
this and all and also all the in all the
other direction so so this this do have
more moves in triangular like this two
Sor it's hard for me to see the thing
two paral lines yes two these these two
parallel these two parallel and these
two parallel so two parallels are filled
in next to each other you can exactly
exactly
yes so you go from these two to these
two from these two to this two you have
more
freedom um so so then let's try to
distill from here what we could Define
as topological
order okay here so first of all the the
genery of the hamiltonian which is
constant constant mean that it doesn't
does not depend on the system size in
this case is four depends on the
topology if I put it on a or if I put it
on a on a plane or
whatever second all ground states are
IND distinguish indistinguishably
locally so so you can you cannot tell in
which ground space in which ground state
You Are by any local observable you have
to really go through a non-trivial loop
on the toos to count the
parity to map between the different
ground States you need a local operator
as as we did as we did in the in the in
this case to go from this sector the
even here to the odd sector we need a
non local move which is this whole
column we move one up okay in this case
of course it's not very long because
it's just two but it could be very long
and it has to be something very long
okay so so the we have to change I mean
there is no way uh so the only way to go
from one sector to a different sector is
to do some again some operation on a
nonrival loop on inter this case it was
kind of going up just every dier from
the beginning to the end okay
okay and these are the kind of the three
things that appear there there are
another two properties that one kind of
would like to have in a topological
order model one is another energy gap in
the hamiltonian so this means that I
have my ground state and then there is I
mean the next the next I state of the of
the hamiltonian has energy I mean which
which is above the ground space but this
energy does not close I mean this Gap in
does not CL close with the size of the
system
and why is this important okay this
simply I mean it's not really crucial
but the thing is that this enforces uh
that your topological pH is robust in a
sense of course if if if you take your
system super big and then very close to
your topological states you have a
product State because it's I mean it has
Al almost almost minimal energy I mean
how can you say that your system is
topical if it's something that is almost
ST which is a
product yeah so so maybe this is related
to Mario's question so
um if the you know these configurations
are perfectly they're very well if
they're not very well connected if
there's a bottleneck in this uh chain
you could get by doing these swaps you
could imagine there would be a very
nearby stage it's not quite uh not quite
ground but it just involves flipping in
the other side of the bottleneck and
then you would so then you would not
have much of an energy here it could be
yes inde you have it yeah you can even
make it kind I know if this naturally
happens in translation veryst but um it
I mean this a good question it won't
happen in all these these Quantum D
models are are known to be G at least
for the for the K latis so so this this
won't happen uh I don't know if the
latis is is not regular or I mean
probably many weird things can happen
but at least in this regular ltis in the
K ltis which is the one which is best
understood and it's known to be a gap in
the in this Quantum model
so and inde in the it's exactly the Cod
so there a m to the to Cod the same
happen the to code happen model what
happens I mean you assume something that
they good good good point good point yes
let me okay uh okay I'm going to delay
no no I
mean I you me to delay to the very last
slide because I will talk about this in
the last slide uh it's okay if you want
me to say something now I
mean uh okay so
soap there various trying to understand
the scale of a gap
so what are we talking about in terms of
violations of any one of
these I mean in principle The Gap is is
the gap I mean you have your hbert space
and then among this hbert space you
would like to see uh what he means is
that in terms of V
yes Min in terms
v no V and T are equal both of them
because we in the in the AR point and
you can assume them to be equal to one
because of course this Chang the energy
scale so the important thing you fix TMV
the important thing is that the Gap does
not close when the system side grow so
it's constant there's a lower bound it
canate but there always a lower bound
which is uniform in the size of the
system this lower this this Gap can
depend on B and T but it's not a problem
as long as does not depend on the size
of the
system and and why is it constant in why
do you want it to be just constant the
no it's not clear this is why I put
brackets this is what happens here and
this what happens in most of the
topological models in two Dimension but
as we know in three dimensions with this
cubic code this is no longer there so no
this why I put it in Brackets but yes I
are all of these conditions independent
like is for uh ah but is this extremely
good question is not clear at
all difference
and ah
good uh aha so let's take this all up
plus all down and the all up minus all
down you take the rity matx of both is
the same so they are locally IND
distinguishable but you can map from one
to the other just with a single Sigma C
in a side
okay
yes ask does sense
that this you want to avoid because
essentially you would like to I mean
this you would like to avoid of course
you could have it there's no problem
that and this is what happens in the in
the in the in the in the square latis
and this exactly what you want to in the
Square latis you have rbbs which are
very topological in the ground space but
you also have this Stager states which
are pro States and and you you would
like to have only topological stat if we
want in the why you
want maybe after this I don't know I
mean you could call I mean the thing is
that what you call to political order
the hamiltonian or the or the state and
it's also not clear because there are
features that are of the state there are
featur of the hamiltonian there are
features which are POS if you talk about
about excitations you need a hamiltonian
for that uh but to talk about about
these things you only need kind of to
have two orthogonal states which are
equal so I mean depends very much on
this yes I guess the possible answer is
that you're trying to construct such in
order to understand possible such
topological orders and it would just be
simpler uh if you just have one type
yeah I mean in this Cas you have a hamon
for which all ground States
topologically order and you engineer
this Hamilton and you cool it down what
you get has topological
order you have some Pro State you can do
all these things to get the zero state
in the
end okay if I understand right the
motivation is that they are that
physicists are thinking of making some
magic material which when put in the
fridge will exhibit certain topological
properties and therefore we need that
there's only a topological ground state
because otherwise in the fridge might do
something else yes this this could be
one thing but it's not yeah I mean of
course this to depending on your your
perspective I mean you have I mean
matter you have a conrete
antiferromagnetic high in the K you
would like to understand the ground
state this use of thing no I mean you
can have a more Quantum info perspective
you want to construct real states to do
something with them like error correc or
toal Quantum depend on your aim of
course even which is the the best
definition change so I give one in which
I put more most of the features that
people call topological let's say but I
mean this is even the definition is
something that you can discuss okay so I
won't talk about this excitation because
otherwise I won't talk about anything
else uh but this is kind of why you one
if you want someone is interesed I can
tell you later but this is why there is
some super conducting thing going on on
the RvB okay why is related to Super
conductivity but I won't talk about this
because otherwise so what I would like
to do in the next minutes is okay to
first of all talk a okay we have all
these properties that we kind of distill
out of a single example and we like to
see which properties do arise from there
in the in the sense of pting you have
all of these or some of
these what else do you get for free
uh and then is there a systematic way to
construct system with these properties
we have this RB but can we construct
systems with this type of of properties
and
how and how we can make them so related
to the first question so what what what
are what are the which are the
implications of topological order so
first of all it's kind of both are kind
of the head and tail of the same coin so
Topol order systems are
robust uh okay this this this has been
proven by by bra HS and and mikalis
uh uh and the the idea is the of course
this idea is really I mean a bit
misleading but is that okay if I have a
topological system and I I encod my
information in in the sector in which I
am if I want to switch sectors I have to
do something non local around around
alus and this seems to be kind of
unlikely that something like that happen
of course this is completely misleading
is indeed false but but this is kind of
one one idea you can have in mind why
these topological states are are robust
but of course if there are if if if it's
difficult to go from one sector to
another I mean there is of course
something related that then these
systems are difficult to
create because of course you have to
kind of encode something which is pretty
Global uh in the system and then there
is a nice result by by bra some that
show that to create topological order
with a Time dependent geometrically
local hamiltonian one need
a time of the order of the size of the
system okay the proof goes via Li robins
and Bounds but I will try to give a
flavor of the proof I mean just just
Chang in this time dependent geometrical
local Hamilton by by Quantum circuits
that that are geometrically kind of
restricted one one cubit can only
interact in the circuit with those which
are close by
okay so is it necessary that topological
order is robust you mean that if you add
a small conation of course this is this
yeah there are two type of robustness
one is is is the one they prove that is
if if you have your hamiltonian and you
put a perturbation in any one of the of
the of the elements of the hamiltonian
then essentially I mean your system is
kind of well connected to the original
system so the Gap is is preserved this
is what this is what they proved and
there is the robustness related to to to
Thermal noise uh and of course we know
that that many of the systems like to
code is not robust against thermal noise
so of course there are two two different
types of robustness uh but so yeah this
is kind what's the second type uh is
okay you put thermal noise so if if if
if if if you you have you have your I
mean you are never at zero temperature
so if you if you increase the
temperature then excitations start to
appear in the system with some
probability and since for most of these
models or Le in the 2D models to move an
excitation cost no energy at
all the moment you have one you can move
it around the to and you are out of the
of the game and and you get excitations
no matter how small you take the
temperature as long as long as it's not
equal to zero and all in all these to
these systems essentially for any
temperature still bigger than zero you
essentially lose the topology more or
less more or less at least okay some of
the feature of the topology at so the
difference is that one is local the
other exactly no okay no yeah you can
see like that if you want yes
yes uh okay so let's try to prove this
it's pretty simple the proof so so
imagine I have my my okay I my my my
spins arrange in a
ltis to the but for Simplicity let's
take a line the proof doesn't change at
all simply that it's easy to paint like
that okay and then I start with with
with with a non non topological State
and I want to create a topological
State okay then since P one is
topological there exist an orthogonal
State 2 to it for for which for all
local observ they give exactly the same
expectation values because they are
locally in
distribution now what they do is now I
with I start up there with S 2 and I
reverse the circuit you Daga okay or
star and I get another state which I
call
plda of
course clda is orthogonal to Z because
she's acting with the same unary in
orthogonal states of course Unity
doesn't change
orthogonality and now we will see in the
next slide that indeed now Z has exactly
the same expectation values for all
locals and therefore since there exist
another orthogonal
state uh with the same expectation value
for all local observable this means that
SI Z was already topological in the
first
place so did you follow the argument
that's that's some assumtion on you no
no
no okay we'll see assump exactly we will
see that as long as you so the depth of
is smaller than the system size this
will be
true okay
but you you say that uh within a for a
certain depth you you cannot get from a
topological to a non-topological is that
what you were saying
from yeah or vice vers vice versa but
for big depth you you can yes for big
yeah as long as the depth is the order
of the size of the system you can but
then I could like do it again and again
and again and I mean getting from here
to here consists of doing small steps
and at some point it has to flip from
topological to not topological of course
of course I mean yes yes yeah I I
completely agree so so so the the thing
is uh yeah yes I completely agree I mean
so the only thing is that of course the
what I'm saying is that is that H if if
so the only the only thing that this
proves is exactly what it proves okay so
that if there is another orthogonal
state to this that such that
this both are exactly equal for all
observables local observables and this
depth is geometrically local and and and
the size of the depth is is less than
the size of the system then the same
happens for for
I must say that the fact that there is
an orthogonal state that that that has
the same local observor in principle
does not imply that the system is
topological because the same happens for
this all up versus all down things I
mean you have all up Plus or down uh
mean this GSC type State this also takes
time to create I mean geometrically
local so so I mean it's true that this
this does not give really the
topologically order but but this is it
gives exactly what it gives nothing more
yes so in this slide you have changed
gears and I am not sure probably I won't
understand after you answer but let me
ask so uh so the lines the lines mean
just the interactions in your grid and
so that and so that these are those
fixed interactions that you talk in the
no no no no no no no this is time this
is time so these are these are my cubits
this is time and these are unary
Gates a
cqu how does it relate to your what you
have said previously like those local
interactions or no they has nothing to
do inde this what I'm what I'm trying to
show here is the fact that these
topological States topological States
now some anything with these
properties doesn't have to do with the
resonating balance bone or anything I
mean any any state which has these
properties will be difficult to create
in the following sense
you just assume a two dimensional thing
so the picture should have been three
dimension layer yeah every layer is
thinking every layer is yes yes this
exactly so so this this should be a 2d
ltis and this should be interactions on
the two thees but for Simplicity I'm
drawing a line so my other question is
that you don't insist on the exact same
interactions that that we saw in the
previous picture or the no this can be
any any any Gates this can be any Gates
yes any Gates as long as simply with any
Gates you cannot duplicate the ground
state of the yes of the system of the
previous slide is this with with a
custom what circuit you
build it's must be
local but you cannot create the ground
state of the of the system is so exactly
as as long as this is not yeah it's
small let's say yes yes are you trying
to prove that the depth is um is equal
to the number of
cubits so what what you like you're
trying to prove the depth yeah exactly
I'm trying to prove that this depth
should be the order of the of the number
of Cub if I start with a pro state for
instance and are you assuming that can
only interact yeah yeah geometrically
local yes I'm assuming geometrically
local yes yes and in the case of a 2dus
do you still get linear or do you get
square root um uh I I get get linear in
the in the in the so if I have L * I
guess
l
so okay
so uh the proof is super simple so so
what I'm going to show so I have I have
I want to show that
a0 is equal to
a and then I know that that SI Z is u d
one and the Z is u d 2
and then I want to see that this is
equal to this and then the only thing I
I need to show is that u a Daga is still
a local
observable because I know that P one2
gives exactly the same expectation value
for any local Observer can you define
what the local Observer is anything any
OB that acts in a contractable region if
I have a tus I have a region which is
contractible any OB which is supported
in a contractable region this is that's
the only thing okay so it does not wrap
around the to
definition and then it's it's pretty
easy because what I do is I I I draw U
Daga a u so this is new Daga this is a
which is local and this is
U okay and then since one is the Daga of
the other things start to cancel so this
cancel with this this cancel with this
this cancel with this and then I don't
have any of these three and then this
cancel with this this cancel with this
and so on and so forth and they get
exactly
this okay
we have a kind of a light
cone and then of course now this is a
local operator because it only acts in
this lines the rest is identity so I
mean of course to to go from here to the
end of the system since this is a light
cone I need that this depth is
proportional to the size of the
system and that's that's it ESS
okay I you see pretty
easy again I mean this this is only s
short of the poal order because there
are some states like these GSC type
States like the all up Plus or down
which have kind of the same feature if
you want to start in a in a in a product
State let's
say um so okay so
now I won't be able to talk about this
okay so I would like to say just three
words about how to construct the
politically order systems and for that
the probably the best way the all known
examples fit into this into this into
this language of
peps um and then okay just just just one
one one probably one one slide is is
is about I mean peps is something for to
understand you I mean to really
understand how how how do you need some
kind of uh some kind of notation which
is graphical and it's this box leg
notation for tensor so I mean it's I
have a box with one leg then it's a
tensor with one index which a vector
okay you have a box with two legs it's a
tensor with two indices which is a
matrix then joining legs is tensor
contraction so for instance if I have
two vectors and I join the legs this is
just the scalar product because I
identify the indices and I sum over them
I have two matrices and I join this legs
then I identify the column index of a
with the row index of B and I sum and
this is matrix
multiplication and then if I for inance
sandwi a matrix between two tensors then
I get this this s this expectation value
of a against B and
W now if instead of two legs I have
three
legs I can understand this as a sequence
in I in this leg of matrices in the
other two legs and then if I draw
something like that then what I do is I
fix the value of this indices then what
I have is matrix multiplication and then
a trace because I'm identifying the row
and the column index I'm exing over so
this picture up there is nothing but the
sum of the trace of a i1 a I2 a n of a
the canonical basis Vector A1 a and this
is called a matrix produ
State Matrix what matrix product State
because a state which says that the
coefficient is made out of product of
matrices product product product State
product State okay the same you can be
can be done in two Dimensions forget
about this now so in two Dimensions now
I have a tension with five legs so
up down left right and you have another
leg which is coming out of the out of
the
Blackboard and then if I contract
through a 2d L I get I get a a state and
this state is called a
peps and
then the way to understand topology in
this peps is the fact that you have a
gauge symmetry so the fact that this
tensor there is a for a finite group let
say G equal to C2 so that the tensor is
invariant and they acting with for
instance c c CC so only this property
give rise essentially to all the
topological features of the PS only this
property and okay to see it I would need
another talk I was very very optimistic
in preparing this one so but this is
kind of what what what one can show and
the one of the crucial steps is that one
can make these Loops these small Loops
grow for if I take two tensors and I
apply this equality I guess c c c and
another here and the middle one cancel
so I get a loop which is bigger than the
previous one and I can make this bigger
and bigger to show that any contractable
Loop
vanishes non-contractible Loops don't
vanish even if they can be arbitary the
form and these non-contractible Loops
are associated to the different ground
states in the Hamilton which are locally
equal
okay and okay excitations are open
strings and one can understand many of
the things but okay like the statistics
and if you're interested I can explain
to you later so let let me just go back
to the to the questions oh the end of
the question simply and then uh so so
just just uh one can create more and
more weird models just changing the fact
that you have this kind of local tensors
by something which looks more Global but
they still have the property sorry what
is the restriction on the what is the
Restriction that the
Symmetry G should satisfy
no that you have some some
representation of the group that that is
invar under the T if you apply here some
ug ug Daga ug D ug the tensor is in
under that this is what this is a
crucial thing but now you can go beyond
the group the group uh scenario and ask
for more General kind of mathematical
structures with behave similarly that
you have some some kind of global
symmetry which is not group like but it
still has a property that if you have
one like that and one like that it kind
of glue and you get some some big Loop
because this is a crucial property to
get the topology this glue in and get
and getting bigger loops and there are
for in h algebra you get something like
that when you have kind of Twisted
groups with elements of the thology
group that are many many weird
mathematical objects in which you get
this type of gluing things and it GES of
course more and more and more weird
topological models what is the condition
on the groups that gives you topological
order all all finite groups give you
topological order except for identity oh
no any non-trivial group of course the
trivial group doesn't but any
non-trivial group gives you topological
any fin one okay uh and then of course
the question is if you want classify all
possibilities so is there a way to
classify all possible symmetries that
has this kind of glue and grow property
of of looks I mean is the only
possibility to get topological order in
peps this thing or is there a different
mechanism and most important is there a
peps in any topological phase in such a
way that if one understand what happens
in peps one what happens in our
topological models and finally what
happens in the 3D Cas so this is kind of
all this kind of program trying to
classify topological faces and I think
peps is one of the right probably the
most uh the best approach to no is
because essentially it Eng gloves all
known topological models but of course
there could be ways I mean things things
out um okay there are more related to
the resonating mod State uh which are
related to the fact that in the real
case you don't have this you don't have
orthogonality of the cetes and there are
many many problems arising from there
and the first problem is that in
principle there is no hamiltonian even
you can write up having the resonating
bate State okay but but this is again
for for for questions offline because
I'm out of time so thank you very
much so uh yeah go ahead so you say the
RvB is that way functional looking for H
you said it was the ground no no no no
but this is the real rbb now without I
mean the other one was the
simplification of assuming everything is
orthogonal and I'm assume the time in
the and this is the real the real one I
have really a spin half particles
everywhere and I take the resonating b b
as the real equal superposition of
singlets now real singlets everywhere
okay is there a for which this is the
unique ground state up to the four I
mean the the four the genery coming for
topology we showed indeed in 2012 that
there is one but uh and it was this was
improved by so and others in this year
but this this Hon act on on a whole star
of course it they act on 12 sides it's
pretty big so it could be that even the
antier Heisenberg has the RvB as going
state or something close to a so so the
thing is if you one could give better
Hamilton and even for those we know we
don't know if they are gapped or not
okay
so can you for this of course of course
this is this exactly this what what I
wrote here it's exactly this this this
is the the the hard integral this is the
comultiplication of a fin dimensional
Quantum group this is antios and this a
representation yes yes yes yes yes yes
so this this exactly this
yes for Le groups it might not lead to
uh it's not clear how to make it with
continuous groups uh for find group is
clear the group is continuous is not
clear at all how how you do this and you
have examples where it doesn't lead to
or it might I mean the construction
doesn't work doesn't work yes yes but
apart from that yeah so am I right to
understand that basically the groups are
fundamental groups of the space and the
what do you call topological order are
you're counting the homotopic classes of
your
space uh because the the the moves there
are homotopic moves where you can find
all the homotopic equivalent
uh spaces when you start from somewhere
when you say they can't move between
places because you have a basically
equivalent class of all the all the
holes in the in the space I don't know
if this is like forly known or formally
known not there are connection with with
with with homology but but no it's not
clear to me now that that is because you
said with the toric code is that2 yes CU
that's just uh like the fundamental
group but you take the formal product
it's not a free group that to but if you
take the formal product it is something
looks like this for the tourus I don't
so the the groups here are acting on the
spin space and actually even not quite
that but not on the not on the spatial
structure anymore so there you know
there local represent the the special
structure with with your spin no no so
the local particle has some internal
hbert space which is totally
disconnected from the
geometry so there two two totally
separate things and this is the the
group he's talking about is more acting
on the the local particle rather than
the spin so you have highly non-trivial
things even in the plane I don't know if
this if this this this you can have all
this non non ailan braiding in the plane
I mean you don't need to for that
so different things but one is simpler
than the other because I mean certainly
the homology group is relevant to the
bigger question there is more into that
than just theology group itself yes it's
clear of course that the number of for
the number of holes has to do is related
to the the genery of the hamiltonian and
you count kind of the at least in the
ailan case you
count exactly by the number of of of
holes let's say in the nonan in case
there there are more things related to
the structure of the group itself and
not just of the topology that
count but so there is some relation but
I don't know if there is uh I mean how
how how neat this this is
known okay uh if that's all the
questions for now let's thank David
again